warm greetings from liverpool eric
how's prep for not a gm going hope it
goes well for you
oh thank you thing duster
i'll be honest i haven't prepped too
much
um my match has not yet been scheduled
two years so i'm not sure
when it'll take place
um i'm sure we'll schedule it sometime
over the next like week
uh
so i should probably start preparing
maybe this is some form of preparation
slower
more instructive chess
i might mix up the openings a little bit
this stream
um
just get some fresh lines
but maybe for this game i'll stay within
my comfort zone my main rapper tour
also happy 25 months to vinnie chase
thanks for coming back yet again
so this line is uh
it's what i like to call the ray robson
variation
ray robson made this popular
many many years
ago my opponent seems prepared
yeah queen c2
[Music]
queen c2 played really quickly too
um
because the main moves are actually like
takes takes or a3 so queen c2
i think i'm supposed to play knight d7
here
and if takes uh we would transpose into
a line that after takes takes black has
a really nice move b5
which solves all the problems
but rook team one
okay i'll admit i don't think i've
encountered this ever before so now i'm
on my own
goals
also i am now born
my goal is to stay focused
take it one move at a time hopefully
avoid blundering anything too major
with rook d1 it aligns with the queen
uh so it's probably best to move the
queen off the file
now i could still consider taking or
taking
uh well not taking immediately because
uh bishop would hang but like take and
then take the problem with bishop d2 is
it helps white develop
and i'd rather leave the tension
so yeah i like queen e7
yeah this was my third day in a row
playing a shield tournament
first it was blitz and then classical
and now
or no blitz rapid now classical
so light blitzing out every move it's a
little bit unsettling
um
[Music]
let's see what to do here i could
now my queen does help support the
bishop so i could consider taking
which
i mean i'm temporarily up upon if i take
i'm temporarily up two pawns
if e5 knight d5
e4 wow
yeah i have no idea this is like prep or
just
my opponent making things up
okay so let's imagine i take
why it has a bunch of options why could
take i could take i could take there's
even pushing
if ever push i have knight d5
and if ever it takes then
e5 is no longer a worry
so take let's say queen c4
between c4 i take on d2
and then play e5
and that's that's one of the goals
actually is to get a nice pawn center
so i'm spending most of my time here
trying to predict what white's going to
do
after i take
i mean let's say e5 knight e5
uh maybe white can win back both pawns
takes
but worst case scenario we got some
structure where
i lose back both pawns
and then i'm going to have a plan of
bishop
bishop d7 to c6 now i'll be controlling
d5
rooks can come in
yeah
hopefully it's okay we'll see what
happens
white has a lot more time than they
started with
thank you jeeves booster
yeah this is my first game of the stream
for everyone just joining
um
white's still playing quickly
rook takes d4
so now i have b5
does my opponent play more blitz
i'm blitzing rapid
um
[Music]
okay so i could play b5
which sometimes walks into stuff like a4
i could also play knight b6 here
the problem is this is a pin and white
might be threatening b3
there's actually a funny line i'm
looking at knight b6 b3 and then e5
where i sack the pawn and then queen c5
hitting this and this
i guess white could move back there
ah then i'm still pinned
and if i take take b2 unfortunately
there's queen c3 in the end
so how to do this
and this is a very obvious threat b5
should be considered
b5 a4
i don't really like for black but maybe
it's playable
knights
huh
let's look at knight b6 again
knight b6 b3
e5 takes
and something like bishop e6
another issue is e5 and then
95 and then b3
wait a minute i have queen e1 in that
line
wait wait wait okay so
that's my thought process during a slow
game
knight b6 b3 e5 takes and then queenie
one check here and then here
and that looks really good for black
so i wonder if we'll see e5 first
the problem again with e5 is it gives
away d5 but then b3
oh but then i take
completely forgot i could just take and
both yeah both queens would be hanging
but that's fine with with me
so maybe more logical is some like
knight d2
but knight d2 queen c5 hitting the oh
not really hitting the rook
okay i'm gonna play knight p6 i don't
see any
too many other candidate moves
welcome back to more people welcome back
to matt black matt
uh
opponents still blitzing
so this diet this actually is opening up
which creates opportunities for knight
g5
i'll still have g6
i'll still have queenie one ideas too
so
let's do this
okay h6
so h6 knight g5 looks scary but then
queen e1 bishop f1
and then f5
and then ampassan then takes i think
it's okay
once there's rook h6 sir
stopped for
0.66666 of a year woo
oh nice
eight months
there's a math out up there
two thirds
i really don't have too many moves here
there's this this or this
uh let's play this
yeah the rook's useful on h4 because it
it still pins upon
and it tries to attack my king
subbing so i can watch the vod later
smile
oh
thanks for subbing
that's one of the perks okay now queenie
won
and this is absolutely terrifying
i hope i didn't miscalculate
white has one legal move
opponent taking their time though
it's usually
a very logical tip
you shouldn't take your time if you have
one legal move
but maybe white didn't see anyone coming
a little bit flustered here
okay i should really be calculating
though that's another tip if your
opponent's taking time on one legal move
i shouldn't be sitting back and relaxing
so bishop f1 f5
takes and then
[Music]
i'm considering taking with the rook
queen h7 king fa queen h king
e7
queen takes g7 king d6
and then i'm hitting the knight and
threatening
f2
[Music]
can you play a jerome pretty
uh maybe
uh
pretty pretty a lot of pretty
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty
pretty pretty please
okay
um
[Music]
yeah today's gonna be more instructive
than usual
and less meaning
so big surprise why plays bishop f1
the thing i'm scared about is
oh there's almost a funny line
okay
it's going to take some time to like
fully digest what's going on here
so if i take the knight i get mated
at 5 is probably the way to go the thing
i'm scared about is f5 on passant and
then
like there's queen g6 ideas and i don't
know this line is actually working
because f5 takes takes wini7 king f8
queen h8
king e7 queen g7 king here there's
knight e4 with a fork
if i play king d8
there's my f7 which doesn't look great
for me
[Music]
now i could consider g6
as a way to try and just get a playable
position
but g6 is still weakening like
after rook h6 there's a threat of this
king g7 doesn't seem to help there
so i should really be calculating uh f5
on poisson knight f6
and then there's a move rook h6
where white could maybe try and force a
draw because after it takes queen g6
i don't think i'm getting mated but i'm
getting prepared
but f5 takes
i think this is forest knight takes
let's say queen g6 immediately
then my knights hide down
i wonder if i have like bishop e8 rook
h6 or bishop d7 or h6 bishop e8 there
it looks playable
everything's really terrifying
but i think i just have to go for it
because what else to do
other options don't look good
wait a minute wait wait wait i'm
miscalculating after this takes takes
queen g6 i can take the knight
and this isn't me because i have one uh
i have an escape king f7
okay maybe things are
okay but maybe not we'll see
thank you i'm ocean born
i'll come back summing for 11 months
wow
[Music]
my queen is just oh no my queen's not
trapped
the queen's almost trapped but i do have
queen a5
i miss knight f3
and i have three played really quickly
like i spent all this time considering
like the
the more forcing options and white just
retreats tonight
i mean there's some logic but uh
okay i could move back to b4
but let's play queen a5 because i don't
want to align with the rook
i'm losing the pawn anyway
queen e5 with a blunder the queen
maybe queen f5 here
like offer the queen trade
try and fix my structure
i do have to play quicker too
like this is a classical game but i'm
already getting kind of low on time
yeah afterwards i'll have time for
analysis
the postmortem
yeah i think white's just like treating
this as a rapid or blitz game
uh rather than a serious classical game
um
because now now i feel
slightly more comfortable
[Music]
for a few moves i felt really under
pressure
so now i can uh just trade rooks
at least offer the trade neutralize the
sound of the rank
white could play this move
okay now there's a decision to make if i
take with king i allow some
95 take with bishop
yeah taking with king is probably the
more principled move even if 95 happens
king here
white might get some outpost
but i hold my ground
and i eventually want to play rook c8
so white still has more time than they
started with
b3
okay so rook c8
i mean g5 is also an option
and kind of moves are roxy da g5
i like rook c8 because it prevents rook
c1 and prepares rook c2 if knight c4
there's b5
let's do this
okay
very logical but i do have rook c2
i don't want to allow a draw
although it's tricky now with the king
and bishop aligned
i kind of miss uh prospective rookie one
but okay rook c2 attacks tonight knight
g6 here here
[Music]
i don't think mike can force repetition
i mean i might have to play some sad
move like king g8 or walk the king to
c8
let's go for this
yeah here i was thinking knight
e4
which obstructs the file and also
attacks the pawn
although i don't know if i'm threatening
to take the pawn there
it also frees a square for the king
and f3 is
is actually kind of strong because this
is a
the more i'm looking at at it this is
more of a threat
i wonder okay after
94 knight d4 rook d2
you relying on some intuition i mean
this is a move that
assuming it doesn't feel tactically it's
a move i should play
so this is hanging this is hanging
yeah the plan was to play rook t2 here
because white has some ideas of f3 and
then if my knight moves there's my g6
hitting this
so i have to make a counter-attack
yeah if i played rook f2 there's rook
takes e4 removing the
defender of the rook
oh no
i think i finally blundered
or did i
now i still have rook d3
i have to take it
i miss the fact that knight c4 is
running two two different things
but i do have this move
uh
[Music]
what else to consider even
i have a really weird idea
i get so crazy but it might work
is to take on a2 say oh no my knight
i don't i don't even want to say this
idea just in case my phone is watching
um
i'm going to calculate silently for a
moment
or at least calculate with minimal words
there there there
there there there
i think this leads to a draw on end game
it's such a cool concept though
maybe there's some chances to play for a
win
let's go
let's also think
but not for too long
oh
okay i think i'm gonna go for it
i mean this is a cool concept is to take
on a2
f3 is coming and then b5
and then the only safe square for the
knight is to move to e3
after which i can save my knight
but this is a problem yeah i likes just
blitzing this out
is we get into this end game end game
[Music]
and this is kind of hard to win
um
[Music]
especially because my king is cut off
maybe i can start with a5
and then this
yeah the problem with white playing c5
is now
uh
maybe it's still a draw
oh it's still going to be a draw
or is it
any chance to play for a win
if i take
huh
it is frustrating when the opponent
blitzes out every single move
even in like complicated situations
rookie 7's good though
uh i could play g5
wait i wonder if i can play g5 and then
walk my king in
that's interesting
i'm still playing for a win here
i think i should start with g5
still watch my time so for k7 i take and
defend
so rook c7 now the the plan is to play
king g4
and then just go in
yeah so now here
it still might be a draw but i'm i'm
definitely playing for a win
[Music]
if i play here there's f7 but here
there's no easy check
now the question is what move order i
want to play
if i want to check the king or take the
pawn first
and there's even like rook c5 but
maybe it doesn't matter either
probably take the pawn first
okay now it's a question between rook c2
and rook c1
[Music]
your opponent seems really talented at
using stock fish
i don't think they're using an engine
though because if they've like if they
were i'd be losing my now
they're just blitzing out moves i think
it's just someone who's treating this as
a blitz game
also yeah don't uh
well we can always analyze afterwards
we do have the cheat command which just
provides etiquette for
certain situations
um
check or check
tracker cut off
wait a minute okay i have to calculate
here here here
here here
here here
here here
i think i got a lucina position from
that
so i should start with check
and now check here here g4 okay so rook
c2 king f3
there's other king moves but i think
king f3 is most likely g4
[Music]
and the king has to say guarding g3
but i force it away
and then every move comes with check
and then i do this and then it's a lucid
position
so i'm pretty sure this is winning but
i'm not 100 sure yet
um
it's nice having 10 second increment so
i'm not in any danger of flagging
yeah this is a i think it's a pretty
straightforward calculation g4
um
eventually i'm going to win this and
this and the king's gonna be cut off
hey
caught you actually playing chess again
yeah
quack
welcome back to erica amy
you're joining in a nice time too
we're about to have uh
an instructive rook ending
that everyone should know
so this is uh this is a lucina position
one of my first chess coaches taught me
this position when i was eight years old
and uh the way it works is
kind of multi-step
it starts by
the start is cutting off the king
and then the next step is gradually like
working the pawn up to the second rank
in this case
um
yeah we'll keep advancing
there might be a few different ways to
win like i could have probably thrown in
the check
but uh i'll keep walking up the pawn
king h2
king g1
and then g2
and then yeah i can throw in this check
um
now there's a couple different lines if
king f1 i'll have a nice move or
if yeah after rookie at king f3
then i play king f1
and the pawn can't be taken because
check and i win the rook
so i'm guessing white's going to move to
the d-file
nope okay so we're gonna have this
um
yeah and if the rook moves all the way
over to threaten me i can queen because
it's not me because
the rook is uh ready to block
there's a different line in lucina where
black builds a bridge
but uh not happening here
maybe afterwards i can share the the
bridge variation
this feels like it should be some maiden
two but i'm not seeing it
check
the maiden three
king f2
here here and then mate
opponent left the game
okay
yeah kudos to leeches this has happened
more frequently recently our opponents
are leaving when
they get losing positions
um but leeches was very good at not
making me wait more than like a minute
hey it's la fong first of all shout out
to lefong
the fong has a question
there's some bug where it will like a
little toy with me and then
come on me chess
oh i'm gonna have to like keep clicking
there we go
it's like uh
it's like toying with an animal where
you you give it like a treat or you show
it the treat and then you take it away
before it can
actually snatch it
so lefong was asking question about
rosenscore
and promote to bishop trophy
does the bishop have to checkmate or can
simply be discovered check
that's a question for the
developer
um
yeah i i would guess
the way that
the code is like programmed
that it doesn't matter if it's
um if it's directly check or discovery
check
there's probably just a line of code
that says
if promotes to bishop and his checkmate
then you earn a trophy
but uh
yeah the creator of rosenscore goes by
travlar in the chat traveler underscore
um who's a vip
maybe not here right now but
he can probably answer the rosen score
questions
oh traveler's here okay nice
welcome back to traveler
um real quick i want to show just a few
things in
from this game
the first thing was like how to build
the bridge uh
it's one of these end games that
um like everyone should study at some
point
if king d2
there's probably a few winning moves too
like rookie chain and this is probably
winning
but the cool way to win is to play this
move
and then let's say white just waits and
then we walk up
check here check
hear check and the reason for putting
the rook here is to create a situation
where after king
g4
can block with a rook
and the king's too far away
and this is what we call the bridge
the the rook provides shelter to the
king
which provides even more shelter to the
pawn
yeah definitely
i'd say no there there was no like
fairytale abuse in that game
it was just an opponent playing quickly
um
and definitely like some
some good moves too
like i was worse at some point
around here
like even after queenie one
it was a bit strange though
to take a minute
on bishop f1
with other moves coming so quickly
um
i'll give my opponent the benefit of the
doubt that was probably just flustering
like queenie one can be an easy move to
overlook
uh f5 i think was forced
and then yeah originally i wanted to
take here to threaten uh f2 but
white just
is the one to to bite first
it's a power of initiative
knife seven or knight e4 defends upon
yeah this is a turning point white
should really keep the bishop
um
because then having a bishop in that
game is nice
but then
so what happened here 94
apparently i should have taken on a2 but
i played rook d2
yeah i thought this was a really cool
idea
to meet f3 with b5 so it looks like i'm
just losing that knight but b5
this knight just doesn't have a good
square
oh is rook a2 the best move
yes it was apparently apparently like
black still better i thought it would
have been like just a dead draw
but there's still some chances
wow so rook c7
rook c7 was a blunder because of what
happened in the game
yeah and games are tricky
and sometimes positions will look really
close to a draw but it's still
there's still life to them